thank you very much for the introduction
and my name is christian
as you as you heard i am currently
writing code of the cute company one of
the projects that i work with is the q4
python project which is the official
python bindings
maybe you heard the pie site
so that's why i'm so close to see python
development i need to deal with a lot of
internals just to maybe uh to be able to
expose
qt to python users
so yeah the the talk is called learn c
python by breaking it because it's
usually the approach that i i prefer to
learn new things i i'm not really i know
that for some people books works well
for me i'm really lazy in that regard so
i prefer to just break stuff and learn
why that happened
so i know that nowadays the the fear of
missing out is quite large among people
related to uh programming because we
have new libraries languages and
everything's
popping up everywhere and this might be
kind of tricky just to catch up so i
know that some of you will say yeah i
see python internals no it's really not
my thing so in any case i know it can be
scary but don't worry about it
so i put this picture here uh i i'm not
sure if maybe in the chat you can see if
you recognize this thing uh maybe when
you're a kid you kind of like got one of
these things
so i put it here because when i was a
kid usually uh
i had a couple of those because that's
what what you get when you break your
maybe your toy car and uh you get this
motor inside and then you can connect
the battery with it and it spins and
stuff like that so
for me it was really interesting since
the early age and uh
this was kind of like my way of learning
things is the beginning like breaking
something trying to see how it works and
then started to enjoy and do other
things
so uh of course i would love to jump
directly into
show you some code of strange behavior
but we need to take a look at a couple
of things first just to be sure and just
for you to have all the necessary tools
even though this talk is for
intermediate
level i'd said that if you at the moment
are listening are you are too afraid
because you don't know c is totally fine
you can stay around i usually put
intermediate because when i say c
language some people get scared and this
will not be scary i promise
so first of all
see python maybe some of you thought man
is this a typo or something and i'm
pretty sure if you watch the previous
talk you kind of know what is coming on
the next slide so here we have four
sorry six different terminals uh i will
give you a couple of seconds you can
check them out all out
can you see what is the difference maybe
you will see that here we have like
four symbols here we have five symbols
but the code itself is the same in all
of those terminals so if i go to the
next slide
you will see that only the last one is
the python that we are more used to it
the item that we know so you have there
um
micropython pi pi gigaton which is the
java implementation rust
eras python
piston and python itself so in previous
talks you already got like we have
different implementations of python
right as i said already we have micro
python rust jython in java pipeline
written in python and piston we have
others like stackless python r and
python pigeon
and c python is the main one so that's
why usually we say when we are talking
about python in a more colloquial way we
usually refer to the interpreter that is
defined by the c python code
so what is the c python code um if you
go to github python c python you will
see that there that you have
the official repository of course that
will have all the developments so when
you get it you will get the latest and
the greatest
uh but inside there are many directories
took me some some time to kind of
understand what was going on there but
luckily there are many good talks out
there tutorials and explanations that
can you can give you a glimpse of what
is going on there
so this is over all the structure that i
got before preparing the the the talk
you see a couple of directories there
and a couple of files
but uh if i may i said that the most
critical ones so you can maybe look into
it are they of course documentation um
they all the interpretive heavy files
the grammar that maybe you saw since
last version there was a nice
improvement there thanks to pep617
then you have the standard library in
pure python because of course some bits
of pythons are written in python
then you have the modules there is a
standard library in c
and then you have objects which has all
the built-in types this is one of the
most interesting things for me at least
because i was really curious to know how
does python list works dictionary sets
and everything
of course there is also a directory
called python that has all the c python
runtime so you will see all the maybe
there are the functions that are
important if you want to try to build uh
things with c python directly like you
saw on their previous stock
so if you want to build your own python
of course i am saying and not installing
it with double click or your package
manager or whatever just build your own
things you can easily do it
by cloning the repository of course
first
and then you can go inside the directory
and run the configure command if you're
not used to these things don't worry
about it it's only this slide but this
is more like unix focus on how things
are being built
and then you do make you also start
compiling then you're going to specify
if you have a lot of processors there
and finally you will have your python
interpreter so you can see it there as
you see here is the 311 because it's the
alpha is what i got when i was building
this thing
so yeah we need c because we're talking
about about c python so i promise it
will be super brief and super simple
so let's go a step by step side to side
things that you can have in python and c
i know this may be a silly example but i
just wanted you to to give an example so
you are not afraid of looking at these
things so let's go first
comments you see different ways of
writing it
way of importing modules in c usually
you include kind of headed files or kind
of modules
you can define a function there there's
a simple function app with two
parameters then you kind of have a main
function in python but in c it's
mandatory you really need this main
function there so i was trying to write
something roughly similar in python i
know that some of you don't like to have
this instructor but it doesn't matter
then you have some types right you have
first a string that in c is a little bit
weird an integer and a float
you can call your functions there and do
a print i don't like this way of
printing in python but it's just to make
you the analogous to what is c uh so you
will say at the moment yeah but i mean
that's really complicated but is it i
mean we we saw today in the the keynote
how important and difficult types are
the same thing but if we have type
here's type annotations you see that the
code itself it can't look more familiar
to it so it's nothing to
to worry about it i mean i'm pretty sure
that if you can understand the code on
the left you will be able to understand
code like you see on the right
okay but maybe you're saying like yeah
but python is way simpler forget about
zip is it python always really simple i
mean
maybe on the chat you can see what does
this code does
maybe you don't know i don't know you
can let me know afterwards in the in the
breaker room
or whether this code does for a given
number yes you see it could be a little
bit complicated this is violet python
code but anyway so let's uh bear with me
the most important thing you learn c or
at least a little bit of it so you will
be able to understand other things
now we want to start
digging into and try to see if we can
break some stuff there so don't be
afraid it would be really cool to do it
and the first thing that i want to tell
you is that sometimes we we kind of i'm
not saying that python is about project
but we believe of projects that we use
so there are really super strict and
things that work properly all the time
and they have like no further or strange
comments
so what i wanted to show you is that
briefly if you go to dc python code and
we look for a couple of things inside
the repository you will see that we also
find nice things so what if you find a
word to do you see there's a lot of to
do still and
in the whole code so you have things
like yeah this does not run
things like that
so if you go there and maybe you look
for fix me
you will also
so many things that yeah i don't know if
this is working oh this is not correct
see this is wrong
and of course you can go even further
and try to look for sad face events that
people sometimes don't know or they
don't know how to bypass a certain thing
so what i want to say here is not saying
like oh look at how bad it is no it's
like python is a project like that
like the ones we write so don't free
afraid of it
okay so now we are going to see python
code but it will be brief i promise you
um okay so first of all we'll use a tool
if you're in in linux you can use gdb uh
you can your mac ldv and windows i
really don't know if you don't know
whether this thing you can build you can
think about it's like a crystal ball
that does some crazy things they allow
you to see through code
so one of the first things that i wanted
to show you is that uh if we do
something like
uh
like this for example i told you already
don't worry about this thing that there
is always this main function so we can
even say okay let's break in main
and then let's write python and then
what something would find that this is
inside python as you see here so we have
an intimate so it's a similar thing that
we saw but there is another function
there called by bytes made okay let's
break there and try to continue further
if we go there we still see okay there's
another function there cool but there is
another thing there
by main main off okay so let's try to
break there
try to go there
and maybe we can see
there is
and still there are other main fun okay
so this method might work of course you
can break in different parts but it's
not really necessary at the moment
but with this tool you can be able to go
inside and see what is going on under
the hood i know this might be maybe not
too obvious but uh just bear with me
that this is something really useful at
some point you would like to see and
start to see where to break things
another option which is really
interesting is the the nice this module
so let's consider this a small the same
function that we have there maybe you
have seen in many talks and when they
run this on this you they get this weird
thing isn't it that's by code it's
totally fine but something interesting
there is that you see that you have two
variables that somehow are load and then
there is this thing called binary add
binary ad so then now maybe you can go
back to your code
and look for binary ad binary ad
we will check does this thing out and go
here
there it is
as you can see this is c code don't be
scared but this is quite simple since
python of course works with this kind of
stack so you will get the two elements
that you have there
right and left and then you will perform
some sum we we all learn now for example
that first we check if there are a
unicode so there are strings maybe
do some special concatenations because
of course you know that string has two
things
and here there is a special function
called by number add so see you already
know like if for example you want to
alter the mechanism of the plus sign
you can do some things here and you're
going to start breaking this code apart
so it's really interesting another
interesting thing here is that you see
if you're familiar with the switch cases
this is
doing things for different options um if
you go up we have the modulo there it
will leave it up here floor divide and
many other things there so if we go to
the line
547 we see that this whole process is
inside something quite similar to a
while true so you can see this is
running all the time and there is their
errors and we are evaluating code and
stuff like that all these mechanisms
which is inside the c eval c file it
belongs to something that is called the
main loop and the the main loop i think
that on this line you will see uh the
evaluation of this frame with this kind
of the equivalent of like what you are
trying to do there i think that even if
we look for main loop
yeah so we have some see we have there
where is it specified where the main
loop is located so this is what is
running when python is running
evaluating everything that we have there
okay
you saw many things that were by object
before in the talk before i was really
lucky that
previous speakers show the interaction
with pi optics and stuff but i just want
to show you what this structure looks
like in c python so this is a simple
instructor maybe you're familiar with
data classes is something you know that
holds a couple of values you can look at
it as an enum but it's not the same but
still
it's a kind of like something that holds
a couple of values quite simple right so
the thing is that uh here you have
something that's called uptype and when
i when i went inside okay what is inside
this obtained
this is all the code that is inside out
type
i'm pretty sure you're gonna even read
it but important thing here that there
are many cases and situations and stuff
regarding like what is going on with
python
here you can see there are many things
specified for numbers for sequences for
mappings etc etc so maybe now you're
thinking okay okay whatever i am really
not sure for this i quit
and you don't need to learn them all the
thing is quite simple if you need to
implement a type that looks like an int
you implement the methods and the things
that are required for ends for lists
same things are required for ads and for
strings same thing
so i just want you to do to get your
head around of pi object as a big box
that you can fill however you want
depending on your needs okay
so a couple of things that i was trying
out for this talk is that uh um i first
i would like to talk about i will just
open my python interpreter here's of
course running python4 the euro python
version i hope that all your of you are
also using it
and which sets the problem that i have
is that uh
every time that i was trying to okay
yeah let's have a simple set here
and i was trying to add a new element i
hope that you can see right yeah
we have it there i was always trying to
then to add another
set
that is of course there is a problem
because that's nothing hashtag so i
never managed to remember what was the
name of the function to include another
set so i really would love to have i
don't know something something like i
don't know add
another
set
[Music]
okay sorry about it yes i forgot that i
need to of course be more gentle i don't
set please
yes and there we have it so we can do
things like to just for you to remember
even if the name is longer i mean it
works for me right i cannot remember
what was the thing if you are wondering
what was the name of the function it's
called update
never came to my mind i'm very sorry
about it
so this is something that bothers me
about the set but just you can see you
can you can break some stuff there and
fix it
so
something else that is also quite
interesting is our lists that of course
there are many modules inside sorry
methods inside the list
we can see a couple of them and i'm
pretty sure that some of you you don't
know it
so let's create now a list again quite
simple list
let's say that we want to append a new
number so you know
i want to append
number three we have it there how do you
free paint an element
we don't have the prepared metal right
because if i do uh prepend or something
so maybe some of you in the chat would
be okay you do the insert but maybe you
can do also the same with writing the
word append
backwards
but then if you do that
then you can of course start your
your number there i don't know maybe
maybe it's useful maybe we can submit a
patch about it
there is something else that lists have
that uh list has can behave like this
like sorry less stacks so you have
something that is called pop
right so you see that with this you
remove and return the knight and
so if i do now a pop
the list kind of
change right
so but i don't know about you but i'm
not really about a lot of pop so i
prefer to use rock so if you try to have
the help of this it's kind of similar
but they say that of course is is
rocking so at least maybe i can try to
rock
and then of course i am rocking out
then the number two
and then of course it maybe that's not
your cup of tea and then you want to
other things that
you want you maybe want to i don't know
salsa out the list
if you do some salsa this is also the
list and it's also steps order and
return none so maybe if this is my list
and i do salsa
you can have you know some salsa mix
there but yes these are things that are
kind of like nice that you can have in
there
let's try to create another list uh
and another example
so let's say that if we want to work
with colors right uh maybe we want to do
like uh something with
reds or we want to do something with uh
i think
oh sorry my camera i think that is
what
i'm sorry about it i was not uh
okay i really don't know what to do help
okay let's forget about this example
then i think that is too strange to to
have this kind of things
okay so uh then of course that's one of
the things that you can maybe play
around with the silly things that
with the list
something else that we can kind of look
at we have a couple of minutes here we
have seven minutes is that
things that in the future you you can
come and kind of count on it so uh there
are many things i have been discussing
already uh with uh
the conference which are the next things
that are coming in in python light
something else that i found interesting
is that uh
well pablo was talking about you know
this really useful way of um
implementing i mean this step 6
5 7 how to get you to point directly
where the or the problems are right
and i noticed that the community that on
another side of the spectrum is is uh
using a lot our tool for visual studio
code i don't use it but i have seen that
a lot of people really like visual
studio codepets so i was thinking hmm
what if we kind of mix these ideas so i
was thinking what if
if you know i mean you know that you
have a bad
list
this is kind of the examples that people
is showing
that maybe we can do something crazy on
that
i don't know
uh called trying to call this thing
and maybe we can revive our friend
clippy and then we can make it i don't
know more like a pets related to it if
you don't like clippy maybe have some
pass from us and maybe you want to do
something different and when we are
doing python and you have some i don't
know some weird error maybe you want to
have something more friendly like i
don't know maybe a little cow that uh
you know it's kind of telling you like
uh when it's going what is going on
there so you can kind of mix these blue
ideas right so yeah this is zero
division error but uh
do you know what happened when we
type zero divided by zero in python at
least in the newest version
i think that is quite a tricky thing
here going on but uh yeah i think that
let's let's not go there i think that is
still scary to to to work with let's go
back to this
so yeah since we are finishing uh now i
was noticing a lot of people that uh
they were struggling a little bit with
all the backgrounds of the stream vr
there were some discussions and some
material at least from the speaker but
did you know that python was conference
ready at least in the newest versions
well if you go here and you try to for
example to write a help with the euro
python
you see that with this at least option
you can prepare your webcam for your
python conference
so i really don't know how
if we can try to do it a real python
yeah as you can see now from python we
can control our camera fit and
everything as you can see it does here
that of course there is the euro python
logo and also my nickname
so yeah that that will be the main
things and maybe you thought already
like yeah there are many details this is
really not for me um
there are other stuff here that are
really important likely was discussed in
the previous talk the first one is the
reference counting thing this is how pi
objects of the lips in python it's
usually kind of a
simple idea right every time you use
something you increase a counter and
when this counter reaches zero then that
object it does stop um
stop living there in the python so
that's why it's get garbage collected
it's a really interesting topic but it
really requires you to have a full talk
or maybe a couple of workshops
something also really interesting that
you see many people talking about a
global interpreted lock and then it's
also it's really interesting for you to
go there and try to learn by yourselves
and something else that also is likely
for us it was addressed in the previous
talk is the module on type creation uh
even though um
dealing with all these spy objects
things might be a little bit tricky i
really encourage you to start now to
clone the repository start to modify the
like a couple of things that i already
told you
and maybe you can start to to check it
out so they said don't worry about it
you can go slowly and also embrace the
python is nothing too serious is
something that you can still copy and
paste here there uh all the little jokes
that of course i was sharing during this
talk i will share them later on make
sure that maybe to follow me on twitter
or on github i will be posting this all
the material so you can replicate all
the silly things that i was doing today
at your own pace
so
yeah i think that that would be it i
think i will still have a couple of
minutes that happened i am not sure if
uh
we have some questions already that
maybe we can invest this time to if not
we can also kind of like look into the
things that i was the implementation of
the codes that i was showing up
[Applause]